we're on our way to sunken city creating
something super fun today but that video
won't be out for a while
this is going to be sort of a
compilation vlog of all the logs I
haven't posted in the past month or so
they'll be a bunch of random clips for
now let's drive San Pedro sunken city
let's roll
[Music]
yeah
you
[Music]
that was fun unfortunately I can't show
you any more in this current vlog of
what we're actually filming but I
promise you the video is coming and it's
super cool and it's very exciting
especially if you're into drones
I got pack up this Nike sport band looks
so good on the ceramic watch I think I
actually look really good on anything
well of late so it's time to go so this
is a pickup vlog and that what that
means is I'm basically just picking up
all of the pieces and video files of
logs that I never actually posted this
past week or two weeks or three it could
potentially review for listen so
organized isn't it the first thing that
we're going to talk about is go yoga I
went on the show was so much fun yoga is
[Laughter]
[Music]
really a cycle
I can't believe it this was so insane
I thought he peed on me I got super
scared but I think I was just sweating
and also the hoods are really sure like
they're heavy it's like when I was
punching you like small so a bit like a
horn for me yeah
next I got a chance to hang out with my
friend Lizzie who was absolutely the
best person ever
Lizzie was in LA promoting her book with
him about June 6 was today it's not June
6 today so you still have time to
pre-order hey Maddie who's here no she's
already here she's already hit no I like
my hair looks crazy
no it definitely does right now I'm
trying to hide my short Maddie oh look
he is so obsessed with Lizzie and by
obsessed I mean like he's been laying
here and just like licking her face for
like the past hour like non-stop
Nik oh your best friend she's already
here they don't eat it they're like go
back in my channel click trash spawn the
living is here in LA the last time I saw
her she was out here working on her show
what did you call it before wait if it's
unzipped but you thought company undress
I'm undressed with Lizzie what like was
I good that's a completely different
show yeah that's not what we were going
for for that one you also have a book
coming out just like your 14th book at
the same that's pregnant well it's
actually not waiting but you've got the
clothes so it's before that's crazy
it is crazy I'm so excited though it
comes out June 6 mm-hmm and it's also
the main audio book oh and you did
yeah it's a lot harder than you would
think that's what I keep telling them
like it's crazy you've no idea it's so
draining reading it again I fell in love
with it all good and I'm excited there's
a lot of stuff that you guys you know me
won't know just you know there's some
things some stories I've heard in the
past but yeah and I'm so excited I want
them all to read it and I learned about
Lizzie things you don't know things you
might already know yeah I'll believe
description yeah he's your girl hi did
you go oh yeah yes my gosh guys your
filth was incredible or just being thank
you so much I'm so glad you came okay
the best part is you edited all the
musical sequences on it
I did I'm such a like so controlling of
my edits and I insisted it was so good I
couldn't believe it and you go back it
was edited all in avid you do know how
do you know Oliver yeah I'd never used
avid which is question Emma it was a
trial child that's perfect now I'm a
nerd and I can use every editing
platform known to man well guys go check
it out you read movie exactly this
actually happened I don't know like a
few weeks ago I went on a date I mean it
was Oh
it's called date with kids who was
trying to get a green card into the u.s.
so clearly I mean it was already doomed
from the start
especially if you know pan this is
probably one of my new favorite channels
if you guys familiar with Stephen septic
he used to be a host on SourceFed and of
course he has a YouTube channel and
since his departure from SourceFed he's
been creating some of the best vlogs
ever like this they got more things what
else
what is rewiring
are you are you already watching sorry I
wasn't doing it on purpose I was just
going to go okay I'll be behind the
cameras husband Galaga
good right now thanks to the death of
corset did you have a comment the
descent that I was glad about my tour do
and I was afraid that she'd be offended
well what they are slightly excited I
was very appreciative of it yeah I'm
actually watching at first I was bombed
no like Jeff Martin is not going to job
and a future I got my friend back
actually is going to develop a big head
you were the one person well already but
it's already basically this gave me
level suit yes sure wait till we tell me
about your high score this is your
pretty oh my god I'm super impressed
apartment I had our top three on their
part we marry her in the world I say
marry only has appointed we you or me I
get a regular wait doctor today this was
years ago
Capri time trial on like the Haunted
Mansion whatever that was I've also been
trying to shoot a bunch of videos so
that I have them so that when I travel
when things come up like me getting sick
which I've been sick for the past week
camera quieter Santa Monica thank you
can I help you yeah do you guys know pop
rocks we do oh great would you a colors
you have by any chance strawberry
watermelon grape raspberry and per punch
okay
I'm not taking care of myself I'm not
eating healthy I'm not working out I
basically am doing all the things that I
shouldn't be doing that is something
that needs to take HR priority I need to
eat better I need to start going to the
gym or we getting outside more spending
too much time in front of the computer
editing it can drive you a little bit
crazy and it's really not that healthy
of a lifestyle but YouTube this
selectable live
just getting over that cold so that's
why I sound like this I can't explain
why I look like this I'm backing out for
yet another adventure and I'm super
excited about it so that's what I'm
doing today I got a drop Maddie off its
babysitter
I just wanted to do a wrap up vlog since
I had all these video clips and know
where to really put them that's what
I've been up to I'm excited for some fun
drone stuff this week so stay tuned for
those videos and I'll see you guys later
again
[Music]